ah shut the front door man oh my gosh my
name's elissa I'm actually a recent
graduate from veterinary school I'm when
Jay sung on the foot and ankle surgeon
my name is Courtney Campbell I'm a
veterinarian specializing in surgery in
Santa Barbara
I haven't played operation probably
since the early 80s
I don't remember if I ever played I know
the game
I've never played operations so I have
no idea how this is gonna go I didn't
come here to make friends
you know the game's not called operation
friends when you're doing surgery you
need to be confident you need to go for
it and if you bump something along the
way
you fix your mistakes I am very
competitive I'm going to destroy
everybody else you guys know how to play
this game actually no no but we're one
thing you don't want to do in surgery is
just wing it
Sam okay so repairs Sam's heart and
charge your fee he'll thank you most
wholeheartedly oh oh I just made that
infinitely more difficulty then he has
Oh butterflies in stomach I think this
game is actually impossible
or not yeah all right well done ooh
student loans yes that this goes to
Sallie Mae thank you very much
so now get the wishbone so when I played
this as a kid this is how he learned
Anatomy oh is this also the wish bones
connected to the thigh bones I don't
know Oh amazing
nice job Peggy buckles on I felt like
knuckles the water on the knee I want to
thank my fellow surgeon funnies going
there's nothing funny about this I wish
I didn't like you guys so much but your
skills aren't that great so it's all
right oh man Wow
he just went there ah so close accepted
both ends
oh my getting easier in this year for
you too much ice cream frozen brain oh I
believe that's facial nerve not practice
it her you just nerd it out right I
couldn't help it a canal oh I make $7
please Wow
stretch away from peg to peg and you
will heal Sam shaking leg this is
actually really hot Oh
I've been working up towards this my
entire life oh wow it's great
Misun Oh
everybody's holding my breath yeah money
pours from the ceiling nice job
maybe fist on that nice job let's count
the money like all good doctors together
so what we do at the end of the day
right
oh you get $2,800 I'm really good
formidable opponents but I think love
them cheated she was born with slender
fingers and the other one cheated
because I think he's been practicing all
week that was a really stupid game well
this is a great game I would highly
recommend this to adults not the
children children should never play this
adults get the benefit if kids want to
be surgeons just play xbox look at his
face
that's Pisces horrified I think he's
made me weird like this since he's not
under anesthesia